and we say hello now on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line to the new
wide receiver in jacksonville florida
part of a free agency bonanza for a team
that is just
switching things around to say the least
from coach to roster to trying to turn
the page from 2021 exciting in 2022
former arizona cardinal now jacksonville
jaguar christian kirk here on the rich
eisen show congratulations to you sir
thanks rich appreciate you having me you
got it so have you are you already in uh
north florida duval however you're
already there you already moved in or
moving in what's your what's your life
like right now christian uh not yet
currently uh still in arizona um which
is where i grew up and it's home for me
but i'm gonna take off here in about a
week and a half and go get settled in
and get ready for otas but uh just you
know really excited to get into the
building and you know start you know
learning the offense and you know just
getting to work with all my new
teammates so how difficult was it for
you to leave
arizona
christian
it it was difficult um you know it was a
dream come true you know being drafted
back here in 2018 and you know just
being in my hometown you know i live you
know four or five minutes from the high
school that i went to and it's just all
pretty nostalgic you know being able to
wake up and you know drive to you know
the facility every day you know the same
street that i took to you know go to
football practice in high school so um
you know it was you know a tough
decision but ultimately you know i think
you know going to jacksonville uh you
know the more i looked at it was just a
no-brainer for me and you know just
continuing and my journey in the nfl and
just you know putting me in the best you
know spot to you know help you know
myself you know keep ascending in the
league and help you know turn this team
into a winning team uh like i know it
can be so um was there a chance that
arizona could keep you sign you was
there was there a possibility at all
yeah no there's definitely a possibility
um you know me returning to arizona you
know along with you know a couple of
other teams uh that were
uh in the market as well and you know
that they were interested in signing me
but like i said ultimately just you know
really drawn to you know what coach
peterson and you know trent belkey are
building in jacksonville and it was just
enticing so what what was enticing uh
obviously dollars and cents
are significant that helps um but what
what was the message that you bought
well i think number one is you know the
opportunity to play with you know
quarterback like trevor who's you know a
young player uh with a ton of potential
and a ton of talent uh you know i think
who showed flashes that you know he can
be you know one of the better
quarterbacks you know in the nfl and uh
you know like i mentioned you know
playing under coach peterson but also
the opportunity to to be you know a
primary target you know on that offense
and uh you know just have a primary role
and and be able to you know keep going
out there and and competing and so
all of it just you know for fit wise and
what i was looking for just kind of
checked off all the boxes for me did you
speak to trevor lawrence before making
the decision did you connect with him at
any point
uh no not not before um but soon after
the news broke uh you know he reached
out to me and you know we've had you
know extensive conversations and just
kind of you know building that
relationship and uh you know can't wait
to you know start building it on the
field as well you're gonna have uh
off-season workout just the two of you
or a bunch of you guys like uh uh
one of those camps that we we hear about
quarterbacks and receivers before going
into a building
yeah 100 i know he did something similar
last year and you know we've had you
know preliminary talks about you know
getting everybody together and i think
it's important you know getting all the
skill skill guys out there and you know
getting that connection down getting the
timing down you know we signed uh you
know zay jones and you know evan ingram
and you know some guys out into that
room so it's important for all of us to
get on the field and you know start
building that connection christian kirk
here on the rich eisen show uh if you
don't mind i know pages get turned in
free agency but i'd like to turn the
page back a little bit
in arizona it seemed that finishing
seasons well not seemed it's it's a fact
finishing seasons were were troublesome
i mean the playoffs were made this year
but it was a
brutal uh
day and night in um in los angeles what
what do you think was off that led to
diff uh troubling finishes in arizona
christian
you know it's hard to tell um you know
obviously that's the number one question
that you know we've all asked ourselves
is you know what went wrong you know
especially towards the end of the season
you know and in that playoff game you
know i think there's a multitude of
things and you know it's hard to just
sit back and say oh it was that um you
know it was just a lack of execution
from us and uh we just we weren't
playing our best football and you know
especially to make a deep run in the
playoffs
you have to be playing your best
football you know going late into the
year and we did that in the first half
of the year but we didn't do it at the
end and so
i think that was a contribution you know
towards it all and you know along with
the other things but definitely was a
disappointing way to to end the year
what type of leader is kyler murray
christian in the huddle on the sideline
and so forth
i mean he's everything you want you know
in a quarterback i think number one you
know he's an ultimate competitor
uh you can just see it in his approach
and you know the his demeanor uh every
time we take the field on sunday that
you know he's he's there to win uh and
he wants to compete at the highest level
and and you know be able to take his
game and his team uh to that point and
so you know he has a relationship with
you know all the guys you know on the
offensive front and uh you know he he
never backs down from you know
competition so i think that's the most
important part you know when you talk
about having a franchise quarterback so
i guess on a scale of nonsense which is
what he called it to construct valid
constructive criticism
uh where would you place body language
and leadership issues with kyler murray
christian kirk where would you place it
you know i would say it's nonsense uh
you know people can speculate and read
into it uh however they want but you
know i look at it as as passion you know
the kids just passionate and you know
people show their passion in different
ways uh like i said he he just wants to
win and so obviously when things go
wrong it's a little disappointing um you
know but it's it's good you know for me
in my eyes you know to see somebody who
cares uh enough to show passion and
wants to turn things around and win the
football game uh that's how i see it
were you one of the photographs that got
scrubbed and then restored on his
instagram were you part of any of those
photographs christian
were you i'm not sure i didn't go back
and check
i probably was but uh i know
there's no bad blood you know me and
kyler have been boys for a long time
uh dating back to our high school day so
you know i know our relationship hasn't
wavered okay and what about coach
kingsbury his ability to close games and
close seasons how did you find that
christian you don't mind me asking
you know i mean we've gotten better
every single year um you know since
cliff has gotten there uh you know
obviously taking us to the playoffs this
year and the year before missing it by
one game uh you can just see the
progress uh you know and there's few
cases where you know like cincinnati
where you know stuff kind of changes
overnight and you know the next season
you go to the super bowl uh it takes a
little longer to keep building and you
know now that he's there for an
extensive period of time you know i
suspect suspect that you know he's going
to keep pushing those guys and
getting the team where he wants it to be
christian kirk of jacksonville now here
on the rich eisen show are you aware
that doug peterson in philadelphia um
had on saturday night's ice cream for
the players are you aware of that
christian kerr
i am he uh he did break that down to me
uh that haagen-dazs is a very important
um you know kind of factor into uh his
pre-game routine so i'll be looking
forward to the ice cream nights you know
the night before the game okay uh have
you already forwarded your suggestions
uh since you are clearly uh um you know
a well-paid if not very crucial member
of this organization christian have you
forwarded this
uh you know i'm i'm not as picky when it
comes to ice cream i'm more of a
chocolate chip cookie kind of guy so
well as long as we have some some fresh
chocolate chip cookies um i'll be pretty
content oh well christian let's let's
let's let's just go next level here the
chocolate chip cookie dough ice cream
mix them both sir do it okay yeah i'll
i'll i'll have to mix that into my
routine and and then and then you you
you know i know chris you're already
saying yeah ice cream sandwich
this man has to play football the next
day but
but you have to you have to you have to
get the
um like the chocolate chip cookie dough
like bites within the ice cream like you
have to you have to like you know what i
mean like you've got to mix them both
and you've got to taste it you've got to
make sure a coach does this right you
have to
yeah we'll we'll make sure to sit down
and get a game plan together so our okay
our night before the game uh you know
snack is is that at tip top shape okay
so uh at seakirk on instagram
um do we need to focus on on looking at
your your instagram to see how you feel
about your team are you that ty are you
because kyler said this this uh that
that that people of of his generation
which you are just take the photographs
off from time to time that's what he
said yesterday do you do that christian
every now and then did you cycle through
um i mean there are a few photos um
maybe i'll go back and archive
uh you know aesthetics are big you know
in our generation and so everybody's
kind of playing with them here and there
um just based off of i guess how you
want your social media page especially
instagram to look um but yeah you can
you can definitely definitely follow me
and my journey i usually am pretty good
at you know posting stuff on my story
and whatnot and and see my my new
journey in jacksonville okay i'm a 52
year old man when you say aesthetics
that's a a word my 13 year old keeps
using over and over again what does he
mean can you help me christian what are
you talking about your aesthetics on
your your instagram what are you talking
about what do you mean
uh when i think of aesthetics i just
think of like display visually like
how visually pleasing is it to to look
that's when i what i what i think of
when i hear aesthetics and uh just the
overall feel of you know what you're
looking at you know is it serious is it
business oriented is it you know hobbies
lifestyle you know whatever whole nine i
mean i guess that's the the platform
that social media has given us nowadays
the ability to do right well i'm seeing
that's great i'm on his page right now
his story you got some new ink christian
what do we got
yeah it's my uh it's my oldest sister's
30th birthday and there's six of us uh
so we all
got roman numerals of you know where we
are uh sibling-wise so i'm sibling
number four out of six so i got the
roman numerals uh four and six on my
shoulder kind of added added on to it
and you know we all got it just a little
a little sibling bonding for her 30th
birthday wow that's awesome okay and uh
who's the the lovely young lady on your
account
as well christian who do you got is that
your wife your girlfriend
that is my my my girlfriend
uh we've been dating for
two and a half years now she's awesome
um and yeah i'm on the clock now so
i'm gonna have to uh i'm gonna have to
uh you know change change girlfriend
here pretty soon okay you're gonna have
to yep you're on the clock i like the
way you put that it's been years since
you've been on the clock so i i see you
also are putting out your workouts i see
i'm looking at the aesthetics right now
yeah aesthetic okay great page because
i'm you know my instagram is you know
occasionally my dogs my wife i keep my
kids off it i don't know how aesthetic
that is a lot of dogs on here but a lot
of dogs i mean what do you what do you
want i mean that's my aesthetic what
christians
he's got a photo with his dog christian
did i use that right in a sentence
aesthetic did i use that properly no
that was perfect
you know you could you could give off
the aesthetics of you know you love
running 40-yard dashes you know that's
that's something that you love to do as
well you can put that on there as well i
could do that but i'm not as it's just i
don't know how pretty it is you know i'm
how aesthetic that is
you know what i mean like that's the
difference
between the athlete the athlete
aesthetic okay very good and so a
christian kirk athlete uh and i see you
already have a photograph of your avatar
of have you photoshopped yourself in a
jaguar uniform have i is that what you
did you did that no
a really talented fan uh did that for me
and so i asked permission if i could use
that and make it as my avatar to
to make the the transition okay very
good i appreciate it so now i understand
how this all works and we'll keep an eye
on just how pissed off you are at your
team
um if that ever happens right christian
is that how it works
yeah i don't think you'll ever get that
get that from me okay
maybe maybe some other guys but but not
me
i usually don't give off that vibe well
one way to help is ice cream so enjoy
that enjoy your enjoy your journey
thanks for the time christian and let's
do this again soon congratulations on
hitting it and uh good luck being on the
clock
thanks so much rich i appreciate it
there you go that's christian kirk
everybody new jacksonville jaguar hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here